hi and thank you for the invitation to
speak today
my name is erin longbrake and i'm an
assistant professor of neurology at yale
university
i'm going to be talking today about long
read sequencing
of the 16s 23s rrna
operon to characterize gut microbial
changes associated with multiple
sclerosis
here is my disclosure slide and
before we really get into the microbiome
part of my talk
i want to just take a few moments to
talk to you about multiple sclerosis
which may be a little less familiar
multiple sclerosis
is a chronic often disabling autoimmune
disease
that attacks the central nervous system
and that's the brain
the spinal cord and the optic nerves
and you can see in these pictures that
these brighter white spots within the
brain spine
represent areas of damage and
demyelination
caused by the disease normally
ms follows what we call a relapsing
remitting course
where an individual whose newly acquires
the disease
has a sudden episode of neurologic
dysfunction
and that could be blindness it could be
an inability to
walk that comes on fairly suddenly
and then usually improves or completely
resolves
with time the disease is relaxing
however so
after being normal for a period of time
the individual would then go on
to have further relapses and with
prolonged time having the disease
usually
individuals acquire disability where
they no longer recover
completely but instead they acquire
neurologic disability
again this could be vision problems this
could be balance
problems difficulty walking if it can be
caused by the brain
it could be a symptom of multiple
sclerosis
with prolonged time with the disease
individuals tend to move from a relaxing
course
into a secondary progressive course
so the relapsing course is characterized
by waves of inflammation whereby
immune cells enter the brain and cause
inflammation
the progressive course is characterized
more
by neuro degeneration
where nerve axons are lost and the
individual instead of having these
episodes of neurologic dysfunction
instead they just slowly get worse with
time in a slow but steady relentless
course and a minority of patients follow
this progressive course even from the
beginning of their disease
naturally everyone who's ever had this
disease has asked the question
what causes multiple sclerosis and the
answer that they
hear from their doctors is that ms is
multi-factorial
we have typically a genetically
susceptible individual
who is exposed to some sort of
environmental
variable that triggers their immune
system to become
self-reactive so their immune system
their
their immune cells actually enter the
brain
the spinal cord and the optic nerves and
create
damage demyelination
and axon loss which
leads to their disability
the specific immune deficits in ms
are many there is no one
cell that goes awry and there's
no one antibody that causes the disease
instead there are shifts in many
different
types of immune cells so one
type of cell that is impacted are the
th1 and th17
cells these are subtypes of helper t
cells
and they are very broadly speaking
pro-inflammatory they make cytokines
that are
that perpetuate an inflammatory response
and these cells have been implicated in
causing the pathology in the brain the
spinal cord
that is caused by a mass interestingly
there are some genetic variations in the
cytokine pathways used by these cells
that increase the risk of ms and
self-reactive t cells are myelin
reactive the ones that
recognize and affect the
nerve cells these are more likely to
have a th17 phenotype in ms patients
compared to controls
uh healthy individuals another type of
immune cell that's dysregulated in
multiple sclerosis are the regulatory t
cells now normally the regulatory t
cells
act in the immune system to just put the
brakes on
put a damper on the whole system and
scale
back any super aggressive inflammatory
response
in multiple sclerosis this subset of t
cells is dysregulated
they are instead of being more
anti-inflammatory
they tend to have a more
pro-inflammatory phenotype
instead of making regulatory cytokines
they're making more inflammatory
cytokines
and so overall these regulatory t cells
have an impaired
suppressive function among patients who
have multiple sclerosis
another type of cell which is just
emerging as being very important
in ms are the b cells and this is
another type of adaptive immune cell
that makes
antibodies but also serves as an antigen
presenting cell
and the b cells
appear to be extremely important in ms
pathology
medications that deplete b cells
actually
almost totally ameliorate the relapses
and the new radiologic evidence of the
disease
so it's b cell depleting medications are
among the most
effective options for treating
ms and while there is no
antibody against that causes ms
um we think that the b cells may be
important
mainly as an antigen presenting cell
that are
revving up and promoting the pathogenic
t cell response
that being said the role of b cells in
ms is still being elucidated and there's
much that's not understood about how
these cells contribute
so i've told you that ms is caused by a
genetically susceptible individual
who is exposed to certain environmental
triggers that
lead to autoimmunity
but the real question is how how do the
genes
and the environment interact what's the
mechanism
by which this causes other immunity and
when one asks these questions even of
the
foremost experts in the field the answer
that you get
feels a lot like jedi mind tricks there
seems to be a lot of hand waving
that goes on and in truth the mechanisms
are not well understood i
showed you this slide earlier that shows
the natural history and the prognosis
of multiple sclerosis but
not everyone follows these guidelines so
you have some people who
have ms who follow a very different
course
you may have individuals who have only
two relapses over the course of their
lifetime and those could be separated by
30 years
you have patients who perhaps have one
or two relapses very early in adulthood
and then have no problems
until they're 50 or 60 at which time
they have the progressive variant of the
disease
and then you have others who have an
extremely aggressive disease course
where they
become progressive almost at the outset
and
continue to accumulate disability until
the end of their lives
and the faces of ms are buried
you can have an ms patient using canes
walkers and wheelchairs
you can also have ms patients who are
out running marathons
and the clinical heterogeneity of the
disease is really striking
and not well understood so in addition
to
what causes ms we can ask the question
what causes this clinical heterogeneity
of
ms what makes these patients look so
different
and the again the mechanism is not
understood
but one feature that stands in the midst
of this equation could be
the microbiome and
as a hypothesis we might put forward
that
the environment changes the microbiome
and shifts the immune response
to lead to this autoimmune response
so let's jump into the microbiome that's
why you guys are all here is to learn
about the microbiome
so let's talk about it we know that
bacterial cells in the human body
actually exceed the number of human
cells and the genetic material
owned by those bacterial cells is far in
excess
of any of the eukaryotic dna that we
have in our bodies
we know that the intestinal condensals
specifically
are extremely important for digestion
from metabolizing medications
producing essential vitamins and the
gut microbiome is really important for
immune system development
um without the gut microbes the immune
system
never develops normally it's a very
un unusual not
very effective uh system
if there are no germs living in the
intestines
moreover the specific gut microbes that
live within us
are influenced by the environment and
many of these environmental variables
are similar to or identical to
environmental factors known to affect
multiple sclerosis
things like body weight vitamin d
deficiency and smoking
influence both risk of mass and the
composition of the microbiome
so the gut microbes do not live
in a compartment they have
very important crosstalk with other
organ systems specifically the brain and
the immune system
so in terms of gut brain communications
metabolites produced by the microbiome
are directly neuroactive and can act as
neurotransmitters
metabolites produced by the gut bacteria
can directly stimulate the vagus nerve
among others
and provide feedback to the brain
moreover there's important indirect
relationships between
the gut microbes and the immune system
which indirectly
can affect the brain especially in
situations of autoimmunity as we're
discussing today
and um the immune system
itself shapes which microbes end up
living in the gut
the flip side of that is also true the
types of bacteria living in the gut
impact how the immune system behaves so
it's a multi-directional relationship
in autoimmunity um the microbiome
appears to be dysregulated and this is
seen across the board in a number of
different
disease states including inflammatory
bowel disease
rheumatoid arthritis and multiple
sclerosis to name just a couple
the ways in which microbiome changes
contribute to autoimmunity are still
being teased out
but those mechanisms appear to include
molecular mimicry and this means
that a microbe has an epitope
and a 3d appearance that's recognized by
the immune cells and
recognized as being similar to a cell
peptide
so essentially the immune system isn't
able to distinguish between the
bacterial
antigen and its own self antigen and so
this is thought to be a
mechanism by auto by which autoimmunity
can develop
where a microbial epitope is cross
reactive with for example a myelin or a
nerve epitope
and the immune system develops a
response to the
microbe and as a side effect
recognizes the brain and causes damage
other
ways in which the microbiome can
contribute to autoimmunity it can just
regulate the barrier function between
the gut and the circulation it can alter
production of immunoregulatory molecules
so
specifically some bacteria produce
short-chain fatty acids
which can include butyrate and these are
known to be immunomodulatory
and promotes usually an
anti-inflammatory immune response
a tryptophan metabolites among others
are also known to have direct
impact on the circulating immune cells
and the
immune cells that are located in the gut
mucosa
and so this these are
various ways in which the microbiome can
lead to or contribute to
a dysregulated immune response and then
autoimmune immune response
so i'm going to go back to multiple
sclerosis now that's what we're
specifically talking about today
and a number of studies so far have
demonstrated that the gut microbiome is
abnormal
in multiple sclerosis and there have
been a handful of papers on the subject
all of which agree
that the gut microbiome is abnormal in
ms
but the specifics of how it's abnormal
vary with the study as you can see from
this table
there's been a number of bugs implicated
and they are not the same bugs from
study to study
i'm going to come back to this in just a
moment as to why this is
but suffice to say that there is
agreement that the gut microbiome
in ms does not look the same as the gut
microbiome in a healthy individual
and this appears to be functionally
important
some studies looking at this took
microbes
from individuals who had multiple
sclerosis
or healthy individuals and they
transplanted those
microbes into germ-free mice they then
gave the mice
experimental autoimmune
encephalomyelitis or eae
and that's the main animal model for
multiple sclerosis
and waited to see how severe
the disease was in these animals
and the mice that got eie who had
no bugs in their intestine that's the
brown line
they actually had a milder disease
course
than the ones who got bugs from
healthy individuals which was more the
control
so the healthy individuals are in the
blue line and that's more your quote
unquote
normal expected rate of ea in this
particular mouse strain
the mice who got a fecal transplant from
ms patients had more severe eae had more
severe disease
ms life disease than the control animals
and so that is
potentially very important
likewise the
immune cells in these animals who had
been transplanted
varied and you can see in the graph that
the control animals had
normal levels of regulatory t cells
whereas the animals who'd been
transplanted with
ms fecal microbes did not
they're they're in the red bar and that
indicates that their
uh regulatory t-cells were not
functioning in a regulatory capacity
and if you'll recall that is similar to
what's seen
in multiple sclerosis patients which we
went over
a couple slides ago this right
dysregulated
t-reg or regulatory t cell response
so we can say that the immune
sorry that the microbiome appears to be
dysregulated
in a mess and that
it's likely based on animal studies that
this dysregulation can have
implications for the severity of their
disease
but human research is tougher than mouse
research in a lot of different ways
and human microbiome research is
particularly challenging
in a lot of aspects so how do we learn
about the human microbiome
well first off we have to recognize that
humans
are not identical this is one of the
beauties of animal research you can
assume that your mice
mouse one is essentially equal to ml3
and l4
within a strain they're genetically
effectively identical
that's not the case with humans one
they're not genetically identical
two they have different environments
they take different medications
they eat different things they were born
in different ways
c-section versus vaginal growth for
example
and they have different habits so all of
these
variables are known to impact the
microbiome
and so any human microbiome study needs
to take into account these what we call
metadata these
clinical considerations um so
this is something that's very important
to consider the next
point with human microbiome research is
you need to decide which
site you want to study there are a lot
of different places where microbes live
in humans and we have to decide which is
the most important
i'm talking today about the gut
microbiome but there are also
plenty of studies on the skin microbiome
the oral microbiome
respiratory or genital urinary tract and
the specific research question that
you're interested in will drive which
site you're looking at
after you've characterized your patients
you've decided which aspect of the
microbiome you're going to study
then you have to decide your tool and
the tools for microbiome study
are many and have changed over the years
so just talking a little bit about the
tools for
microbiol microbial taxonomy which is
the most
common way that people study the
microbiome
older studies were limited to things
that could be cultured and that was very
limited as you can imagine not every bug
that lives in the intestine is rather
readily culturable for sequencing
technology 16s
rrna emerged as the main
way in which we understand the taxonomy
of these bacteria
the 16s rrna gene is evolutionarily
conserved among
bacterial species and so um sequencing
just this one gene or even part of that
gene
can lead to taxonomic identification of
your bugs and so
initially people did full length 16s
sequencing which took a long time
cost quite a lot of money it was very
slow um
this evolved into short amplicon
sequencing and we'll get
into that just in a moment and has
evolved from there
so 16 as our rna sequencing of specific
hypervariable regions is the standard
for
16s taxonomy based methods
of characterizing the microbiome and the
16s
our rna gene has nine variable regions
b1 through v9
and one of the things that needs to be
understood about these is that not every
type of short amplicon 16s rna
sequencing is going to give you the same
data
so certain of the hypervariable regions
are more highly evolutionarily conserved
and others
mutate more frequently the v4 through v6
regions are the most conserved
evolutionarily
and the before region is the most
similar
to the average 16s rrna gene
when you sequence the whole thing
however
v4 sequencing typically cannot achieve
fine detail in terms of the bacterial
taxonomy
so you are limited to family order
genus level identification and
you really can't get to species and
strain level identification with
v4 sequencing if you
include the v2 and v8 regions you may be
able to get a little bit more
fine detail on the taxonomy but then
they run into other
problems with those areas and so
i've just outlined here in this slide a
couple of the
benefits and fallbacks of each
very hypervariable region and you see
that most of them
have preferences for certain types of
bugs that live are more easily
identified in certain areas
and so these are the choice of region
is is important when considering what
your
tool is that you're going to study the
microbiome with
so in terms of ms the existing data are
limited
in a lot of different ways the patient
cohorts have been very heterogeneous
the sequencing methodologies have been
variable
and we've looked primarily at taxonomy
not at bacterial function
so if i go back to this table that i
showed you before
and it said you know this is this looks
very different from study to study
well that could be because we're
comparing apples and oranges
the methodology methodologies used for
each of these
studies was very different um and
so the fact that one's studies saw
decreased bacteroides and another saw
increased bacteroides
isn't necessarily unsurprising in a way
but this does make it difficult for us
to try and dial down to what's the core
truth what is
the state of the microbiome in ms and
some of that we may be able to learn a
little bit better based on improvements
in sequencing platforms
so i talked to you a lot about the short
amplicon
sequencing for 16s and most of that
sequencing relies on the me seeker
illumina platform
this platform can sequence amplicons
that are up to around 300
at a good day probably 250 more
realistically
base pairs at a time and more
third generation sequencing technologies
have changed the
chemistry in such that these pac bio
platform
is now able to sequence 10 kilobytes at
a time so much much longer amplicons
and the use of this platform has enabled
improvements in the 16s technology so
that we're no longer sequencing
just the v4 region for example
so long amplicon sequencing involving
the entire 16s
the internally transcribed spacer and
the part of the 23s
gene is what my group is using and this
methodology
is significantly more powerful than the
short amplicon sequencing and that it is
able to achieve species
and often strain level resolution
um there are certain bugs that it won't
pick up
helicobacter and archaea species for
example
but overall this is a much finer
granularity and allows more detailed
taxonomy than any of the uh
short amplicon sequencing so our
pipeline is to collect stool
at home we also collected detailed
metadata
as i mentioned earlier this is a very
important consideration in human
microbiome research we have it shipped
overnight to our lab
and immediately aliquot and then when
we're ready to process we do so in
batches
isolate the dna achieve the sequences
de-multiplex the sequences
we use data2 to denoise the data and
then align against
an athena database that's a modified
version
that includes the internally transcribed
spacer and the 23s gene as well
um just a short look at our demographics
i'm going to summarize this to say that
we have
a little over 30 ms patients and we have
longitudinal samples on most of these
patients both at baseline and then after
they start immunomodulatory therapy
and we have healthy controls to match
them
and we've collected detailed information
about these patients their diets their
stool habits their travel history
just everything we could think of that
might potentially impact the microbiome
we um again as i showed you our pipeline
just looking at the mock community reads
we're just demonstrating quality
of this pipeline you can see that before
the dota 2
denoising step we do have a lot of read
counts which gets decreased as expected
when um the
errors are filtered out with the data 2
stuff and
the important things to note is that
the post dota 2
sequences that have more than 10
aggregate reads over the course of the
entire data set
is almost identical to that that's
expected based on manufacturer provided
specs about the mock communities
and that after data 2 we have
essentially 100 of our reads are
assigned to the expected species so we
feel very confident this
this is a high quality way of
analyzing these data we then are going
to come back to
our uh our specimens and i'm just going
to take just a quick moment to talk
about ways of measuring the microbiome
we look often at alpha and beta
diversity so alpha diversity refers to
diversity within a sample
how many species can be detected within
a given specimen
you can also talk about beta diversity
which is diversity between
samples so the
top set of circles has a
high beta diversity because many species
are different between
these two organisms or these two um
sets of of data whereas the lower
circle would refer to a low beta
diversity even though
there's a lot of different bugs in that
lower right circle
um they're almost all shared with the
circle on the left so the beta diversity
there would be lower
and in our data sets the alpha and beta
diversity of ms patients are
significantly
different compared to the healthy
controls overall the alpha diversity was
decreased amongst our ms patients
this was most pronounced before they
started immunomodulatory therapy
the beta diversity if anything was
increased in the beta sorry in the ms
patients at baseline
and we then wanted to look at the
overall underlying populations making up
this change in diversity
because the alpha and the beta diversity
tell us nothing about
the specific bugs only that there's a
difference
and we did a analysis of the composition
of microbiomes
which is a data technique that's
designed for microbiome research
looking at overall which sets of bugs
are different
and we identified bacteroides as
relatively enriched in patients who had
multiple sclerosis
so we then wanted to look at which
specific bugs were enriched
and we also wanted to examine the impact
of immunotherapy on the gut microbiome
so patients with
ms typically are treated with
immunotherapy and in our cohort these
are actually
all of these patients were treated with
b cell depleting immunotherapies
and many medications including some
other
immune modifying medications do impact
the composition of the gut microbiome
and we were curious whether that was
part of how these mechanisms were
sorry how these medications were acting
in ms
and so we looked at the species level
identification of these bacteroides
again this was identified at the genus
level as being
enriched in ms here you can see some of
the specific
species which appeared to be enriched in
the ms patients compared to the healthy
individuals
and interestingly you can see that the
most of these species appear to decrease
or the
the trends is more for
a distribution that more resembles the
healthy controls as the individuals are
treated with
immunomodulatory b-cell depleting
medications for longer periods of time
which is really interesting and we want
to flush this out further
so future directions for us is that we
are still increasing our cohort size and
the extent of our longitudinal follow-up
with these patients
i told you that we collected a lot of
clinical metadata into this and that
this
collection of clinical metadata is
extremely important for
human microbiome research and so we are
still incorporating these clinical
metadata into
our analysis we also
are planning to expand this
uh data set into multi-ohmic research
and look also at the metabolites
produced by these microbes and that will
be
yet another very important aspect of how
the microbiome is acting so it likely
won't be enough just to know which bugs
are there and which are not
we'll also need to know what they're
doing what are the
what are the metabolic implications or
the functional implications of this
change and this dysbiosis that we see in
autoimmune disease
so that is my talk for today
i'd like to give special acknowledgement
to bill ruff
upper right picture uh to
ganit janda and to ina cohen my students
who have just done
most of this work and it's a phenomenal
job from all three of them
really made this work possible i also
acknowledge david haffler my mentor
and his lab and my funding sources and
with that
i would like to thank you for your
attention any questions can be
directed towards me via the platform
thank you so much